every day each one of us entertains in
the caverns of our minds a host of
secretly very enjoyable but deeply taboo
ideas and scenarios we fantasize about
the downfall of rivals sudden wealth and
fame being able to reverse and
accelerate time eliminating colleagues
anticipating the stock market thinking
of the death of various people even a
few were meant to love and of course of
having sex with a huge variety of
entirely inappropriate people in a
plethora of highly forbidden or just
pretty non-standard ways the presence of
these fantasies can be hugely dismaying
and shame inducing we contain in our
minds enough explosive material to set
our world aflame many times over but in
truth having fantasies that are sharply
at odds with reality is a fundamental
feature of good human lives it started
when we were very young as a child we
might have enjoyed imagining going to
the south pole wrestling and then making
friends with a polar bear adopting a pet
penguin with a broken wing and then
spending the night in an igloo before
getting rescued by pirates cruising past
in a for mastered nuclear powered ship
in the real world
this would be by turns horrific
impossible dangerous and in breach of
maritime law but in our heads it's
lovely
make-believe is so enjoyable because it
takes a scalpel to experience and cuts
away everything that would be genuinely
awful in reality we don't worry about
children fantasizing we're confident
about the many secure and obvious
barriers between having a thought and
doing something about it in the world we
should extend the same understanding to
ourselves as adults a fantasy isn't a
plan it's a disguised but very precise
acknowledgement of what would never work
but needs to be aired in its form
it's testament to our acceptance of the
way things actually are we fantasize
instead of preparing this is what
distinguishes us from genuinely
terrifying people
rather than fantasize put things into
action the origin of fantasy is not a
failure to understand reality it is
rather a deep appreciation of reality
which for the sake of inner relief has
been briefly suspended the legal system
which makes such a strong distinction
between a thought and an action a
fantasy and an enactment is the guardian
of a very important truth and basic
Liberty which it's taken many hundreds
of years for humanity to secure and must
never again be blurred civilized
societies don't have thought crimes yet
should it still worry us that fantasies
occur to us at all isn't it terrible
that some pretty shocking thoughts do
pop into our minds even if we know they
are just thoughts a fantasy is always
trying to tell us something important
about ourselves even though the message
usually arrives in garbled forms a
fantasy about wealth isn't really a
political thesis about the allure of
drastic inequality it's a way we talk to
ourselves about stress and anxiety we're
imagining a life in which we didn't have
to worry our complex sexual fantasies
the ways of acknowledging certain needs
we know we've had a sacrifice in the
name of loyalty to people we love but
which we need to hang on to nevertheless
at the root of our guilt around our
fantasies is that we don't know anything
like enough about the inner lives of
other people we don't realize how deeply
normal our so-called oddest thoughts
actually are you can be certain that the
most apparently private thoughts you're
harboring in utter shame are active
fantasies in the minds of millions of
others right now our fantasies aren't
signs of evil they are natural products
of the brain the result of the powerful
fact that our minds need to imagine the
impossible to come to terms with the
forbidding sober nature of reality
thinking that our fantasies are pretty
weird isn't evidence that they actually
are it's a sign we don't yet know other
people well enough
you